[Musique]
on la surnomme la perle de l'adriatique
entre mer et montagne dubrovnik attire 4
millions de visiteurs par an jusqu'à dix
mille par jour en haute saison
[Musique]
depuis que la cité médiévale a servi de
décor au tournage de la série game of
thrones elle étouffe sous le poids du
tourisme marine courtaut love each et
délégués de quartier pour la vieille
ville
il se bat pour les 1500 habitants qui
vivent encore dans les remparts cette
plage était le dernier endroit où les
locaux pouvaient laisser leurs affaires
et se baigner dans la vieille ville
mais chaque jour ils doivent reculer
devant la clientèle du bar la quantité
de touristes a fini par tuer l'identité
de ceux des pv des intrusions de ce
genre ont le don d'agacer marine purge
to love each
[Musique]
marina tenait une fabrique de chapeaux
dans la vieille ville elle a mis la clé
sous la porte
son loyer était devenu trop cher voilà
avant c'était mon magasin son ancien
local abrite maintenant à glacier marina
a déménagé son atelier au
rez-de-chaussée de sa maison elle vit à
dubrovnik depuis 1991 et elle a vu le
tourisme transformer la ville tous les
anciens commerces du centre ville sont
partis avant on trouvait de tout dans la
vieille ville
maintenant je ne peux même plus faire
réparer mes chaussures je ne trouve plus
de tissus nous avons trois supérettes
les prix ils sont trois fois plus élevés
qu'en dehors des remparts je fais mes
courses à l'extérieur mais bon au moins
on a des monuments historiques
[Musique]
marina s'est résignée elle va
transformer son atelier en chambre pour
la location
difficile de vivre de l'artisanat d'art
dans une ville axée sur le tourisme de
masse
acheminés en bus et en bateau de
croisière la plupart des touristes ne
reste que quelques heures en ville en
moyenne ils ne dépenseraient que 27
euros pendant leur séjour
selon les données réunies par cette
chercheuse la principale motivation
convenir à dubrovnik et le climat et le
divertissement
seulement 14% des visiteurs viennent
pour faire du tourisme culturel
malgré tout notre patrimoine historique
dubrovnik n'a pas su se positionner
on a privilégié un tourisme de masse
pour un bénéfice à court terme
inquiète pour l'authenticité de la
citadelle l'unesco a récemment mis en
garde les autorités de dubrovnik
si rien n'est fait pour réduire l'afflux
des touristes
la ville sera rayé de la liste du
patrimoine mondial voici l'une des
caméras qui permettent de compter les
visiteurs des caméras comme celles ci
sont placés au dessus de chacune des
portes qui mènent à la citadelle en ce
moment nous avons 4376 visiteurs dans le
centre historique
vous voyez le chiffre a déjà augmenté
nous ne voulons pas interdire aux gens
de profiter des beautés de dubrovnik ni
faire de la ville une zone protégée
ce serait impossible mais nous voulons
mieux réguler en travaillant avec les
croisiéristes et les compagnies de bus
afin de ne pas dépasser 4000 personnes
en même temps dans la vieille ville au
lait symbole des dérives du tourisme un
gigantesque projet immobilier est depuis
dix ans au coeur d'une bataille
juridique
le projet commence là bas sur cette
pente à l'est et s'étend à travers la
montagne jusqu'à l'ouest de la ville au
dessus du port sur la montagne qui
surplombe dubrovnik
en investisseurs prévoient de construire
un golf et des villas de l'us avec un
collectif d'habitants jours au cap or se
bat inlassablement contre le projet
cette montagne est le dernier espace
vierge qui reste aux habitants de la
ville
c'est un site patrimonial si vous y
mettez des villas comme à las vegas vous
manquez de respect aux gens ne pouvaient
pas faire n'importe quoi avec notre
patrimoine au nom du tourisme
[Musique]